[Music]
you might think that you already learned
everything there is to know about the
pyramids of Egypt but many mysteries are
left unsolved thousands of years after
the construction of the pyramids some
scientists found answers to our
questions while others just have crazy
theories to explain all this stay tuned
until the end of the video to learn more
about the hidden chambers that might
have been discovered if you love
mysteries as much as we do don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we're showing you
ten biggest mysteries of the pyramids
you've never heard of the construction
you've probably already heard about this
mystery but most people have never heard
about the answer to our questions
many people have been wondering how the
pyramids were made by men when
technology did not even exist the three
Pyramids of Giza were built around four
thousand years ago for each of the three
Pharaohs at the time ancient Egyptians
had been able to move massive stone
blocks across the valley of the kings
and around 2,000 BC the first and
largest pyramid built by the pharaoh
Khufu still stands 455 feet tall well
the second was a little smaller and the
third one was 215 feet tall it just
seems impossible for them to do this at
that time but a new study finally solved
the mystery ancient Egyptians have been
able to move massive stone blocks with
water they use a giant sled to move the
blocks and pouring the right amount of
water in front of it is what gave them
the chance to reduce friction and make
it easier to pull the sled it becomes
clearer when you look at a drawing where
more than a hundred men are hauling an
immense statue attached to a sled you
can clearly see one man pouring water on
the sand in front of it and he is
probably the most important in this
story but that can't explain everything
and this is why people kept asking
themselves many questions hey guys we
are so excited to announce we're
producing our
original content head over to the trendy
for the best DIYs fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section you let me
hear from you see you there the workers
who built the pyramids you probably
thought that the thousands of men
working for the Pharaoh were slaves or
foreigners after all it was probably
hard to find ten thousand men who wanted
to spend thirty years of their lives
building a pyramid when you watch a
Hollywood movie you can see hundreds of
men being badly treated by people who
force them to work hard every day just
because their pharaoh has too much
ambition but this is nothing but a myth
that we need to stop believing in that's
because archaeologists found a dozen
skeletons of builders perfectly
preserved by sands near the Giza
pyramids they even had jars of beer and
bread for their afterlife which they
would probably not have if people didn't
care about them other archaeologists
claim that pyramid builders were also
paid for their work most of them came
from poor families and were respected
for their work this is why those who
passed away while building the pyramid
had the honor to be buried near it
archaeologists actually know all that
since the 90s
but it seems hard for people to
understand that these men were not
forced to do this but simply wanted to
be loyal to the pharaoh if you think
that it's hard to believe just wait
until you hear the crazy theory on who
actually built the pyramids the aliens
if you're ready for a crazy theory here
it is many people think that the
pyramids were built by aliens according
to them ancient Egyptians didn't have
what it takes to build these pyramids
this is why they use superior technology
offered by aliens to build them and if
you want to push this theory even
further some people think that the
pyramids were not built four thousand
years ago but twelve thousand five
hundred years ago when there was no
civilized human society on the planet it
would mean that the aliens actually
built the pyramids a couple of them were
just flying over the earth and thought
that it was the perfect place to build
something incredible if you want to know
why you'll have to keep watching then
the ancient Egyptians found these
monuments and started to think that the
aliens were their gods and even
worshipped them as you can probably
guess historians do know that the
pyramids were built by humans four
thousand years ago they don't know
exactly why but more questions are
answered every couple of years and
drawings clearly show no signs of any
spaceship or extraterrestrials but
something actually makes them think that
they could have used some help from a
who had an incredible knowledge that's
because many things are just too perfect
to be true keep watching to know what
we're talking about the perfect number
you probably know about the number pi
the irrational number that starts with
3.14159 and continues forever if you
have a circle no matter how big it is
the ratio of the circumference to the
diameter is the value of pi but what is
strange is that the number of pi keeps
coming back over and over again when you
look at the measurement at the Great
Pyramid of Giza for example when you
divide the perimeter of the pyramid with
its height you get a close approximation
to 2 pi it is similar to a circle
because when you divide the
circumference of a circle by its radius
you also get 2 pi we also know that the
slope of each side of the pyramid is
really close to 4 over pi that's a lot
of numbers that not a lot of people
understand but let's just say that it is
too perfect to be a coincidence from
what we know about the ancient Egyptian
mathematics and their way of
representing lengths and slopes their
goal was probably for their pyramid to
exhibit the perfect pi relationship but
some people just can't believe that
ancient Egyptians already knew about
this number and how to use it at that
time this is one of the reasons why they
believe that the extraterrestrials told
them about this if you think that this
is just a coincidence you'll have to see
all the other things that are too good
to be true the North another thing that
is really impressive is that the Great
Pyramid is almost perfectly aligned with
the true north that's because the
north-south axis is aligned with in
three sixtieth of a degree of the true
north-south if you don't understand how
remarkable this is we have to tell you
that the alignment of the Meridian
building at the Greenwich Observatory in
London is less accurate even if it was
built when we had much more technology
to get an almost perfect result it
deviated from nine sixtieth of a degree
compared to three sixtieth with the
problem is that there is no evidence
that the ancient Egyptians used
astronomical knowledge in the
construction of the pyramids it even
seems impossible that they had such
knowledge to find true north because
they didn't even have a compass at that
time an Egyptologist did find a method
to find true north it can be achieved by
using astronomical algorithms we simply
have to compare the rising and the
setting position of the Sun in the east
and the west and bisect the angle
between them we wouldn't be able to do
it either but we can understand that
it's possible no matter what ancient
Egyptians didn't write about that and
this is why some people think that this
knowledge came from a
the Orion constellation we promise that
we're not trying to convince you that
aliens built the pyramids but everything
is too perfect to be a coincidence this
is why we like to make fun of the
ancient Egyptians by saying that they
were so good that they probably came
from another world
this time studies suggest that the
shafts emanating from the King and
queens chambers were perfectly aligned
to the Orion constellation actually the
northern and southern shafts from the
Queen's Chamber did not extend all the
way to the exterior of the Great Pyramid
but people believed that it was just
because they abandoned the construction
the location also changed over the years
but scientists know where they were at
that time this is how they were able to
understand when the pyramids were built
for example the star ko cap is
associated with the immortality of the
soul the star Sirius was associated with
the cosmic mother of the kings of Egypt
then we had the star Alnitak the
brightest star which symbolizes the
association to Osiris the high god of
resurrection and rebirth the shafts
target the stars so precisely that it's
impossible to think that it's simply a
coincidence is it the alien no the
ancient Egyptians probably just really
cared about the gods and what was
shining in the sky above their heads the
planetary alignment these were great
coincidences but you shouldn't believe
in anything you read online if it's too
good to be true
sometimes it actually is too good to be
true some of you might have seen these
pictures of a planetary alignment above
the Giza pyramids people claimed that it
only happened every 2737 years and they
even thought that there was a spiritual
message implied in them they were not
totally wrong but we could still say
that they were really far from the truth
first the picture itself wasn't real it
was posted before the event so it didn't
make sense that they already had the
picture unless it was taken 2737 years
ago which doesn't make sense either
people probably just wanted to make
others believe that this is what they
were going to see on that night planet
alignments do happen quite often and not
every two thousand seven hundred and
thirty seven years and it did happen on
the day they talked about but don't
believe that they were all going to
shine perfectly over the three pyramids
actually you probably won't even see
them shine at all that's because it's
kind of hard to see planets in the sky
if you're not using a telescope but
don't worry we still have many other
things to show you that will amaze you
we have enough real mysteries here no
need to create fake ones the center of
the earth
everything about the pyramids looks too
perfect to be true we told you that the
aliens were just flying above the
Earth's
find the perfect location to build a
pyramid and they chose Egypt and some
people think that there is a reason why
they decided to build it there that's
because the Great Pyramid of Giza is
located at the exact center of the
Earth's landmass according to some
people it is at the exact intersection
of the longest line of latitude and the
longest line of longitude this is what
makes the pyramid an architectural and
an engineering marvel but also a
geographical marvel it is even described
as a massive and indestructible stone
memorial of a complete and faultless
knowledge of the structure of the
universe but there is no way the ancient
Egyptians knew about all the continents
on earth at that time when it will still
take centuries for Christopher Columbus
to travel the sea there is no way they
would have known about that without a
map or traveling across the entire world
when you think that it's exactly at the
center of the earth and also almost
perfectly facing north you could start
to believe that it was in fact built
with the help of the aliens but
historians have already told us many
times that we should stop talking about
these alien theories don't worry even
when we talk about something that is
true we can find more interesting
mysteries the missing capstone many
people have been wondering why the Great
Pyramid of Giza
is missing a capstone on the top isn't
it the only thing missing to make a
perfect pyramid it seems to be one of
the most precise structures on the
entire planet but still this little
thing seems wrong after all the capstone
is the last thing that people put on top
of the pyramid once it's built some
people might even say that it's
basically the most important part of the
pyramid maybe it has never been there
but it's weird to think that the workers
would have left the pyramid unfinished
after working so hard on it other people
think that it was made of gold and it
was removed from there in a distant past
we clearly see why someone would like to
steal it another researcher also thinks
that a sphere was actually placed on the
top of the pyramid it symbolized the Eye
of Horus and the Great Pyramid of Giza
was a place where ancient Egyptians
worshipped the Sun and Sirius the
biggest star in the sky these are just
theories and this question is still left
unanswered this is why we made one more
Theory just for fun the pyramid is
actually not done yet and zombie workers
are going to come back to finish it
the hidden chambers this recent
discovery made us ask ourselves more
questions
it is hard to learn more about the
pyramids because we want this monument
to stay intact this is why researchers
decided that they would use what they
call non-invasive visualization
techniques with 3d scans lasers and
drones to see inside the pyramid and
this time they were just going to look
at
temperature of the pyramid to see if
they could learn new things and they
were really surprised when they started
inspecting the Great Pyramid of Giza
that's because the scan revealed several
thermal anomalies during the cooling
down and heating up phase a six degree
gap was detected between neighboring
blocks with infrared thermography it was
clearly revealed that three of the
blocks were red while the others were
blue or green they think that it might
be explained by voids behind the surface
it could mean that there are still some
hidden chambers that no one has
discovered yet they're still doing more
research to solve the mystery but we
don't know how they're going to do it
without destroying the pyramid but let's
not forget the motto of the Faculty of
engineering of Cairo University just
because a mystery is 4,500 years old
doesn't mean it can't be solved what do
you think about the alien theory don't
be shy to share your thoughts in the
comment section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for
the ten biggest mysteries of the
pyramids you've never heard of for more
stories like this make sure you watch
unexplained mysteries in the sky caught
on camera thanks for watching
[Music]